if not for the coronavirus this weekend
would have been one of celebration
the closing ceremonies of the olympic
games in tokyo japan were set to take
place on sunday
but the games have been postponed till
next summer and the delay
the first ever for the modern olympics
has the athletes finding creative ways
to push their limits and stay in top
form
nancy chen has their story
for years precisely choreographed
routines
perfected footwork and thousands of
miles logged
are performed by athletes chasing the
olympic dream
a shot at greatness as the world watches
when life
can change in a moment a moment
that will now have to wait because of
coronavirus
it's kind of like getting the rug swept
out from underneath you gymnast lori
hernandez captured the world's attention
and gold and silver medals at the 2016
rio olympics like other olympic hopefuls
she now has to wait to qualify for the
upcoming games
everybody was getting ready to peek and
then all of a sudden we're having to
come back down again
rescheduling means another year of
testing limits to their extremes
financially mentally and physically
what do you like about trail running you
know it's quiet
runner kyle murper set a world record as
part of the u.s
distance medley relay team in 2015.
after trying twice before the 29 year
old had been hoping to make his first
olympic team and his final push
i definitely felt deflated at first
everything that i do every single day
is kind of positioned in such a way that
i could run my best when it counts the
most
and then all of a sudden that is
stripped from you
like most of us olympic hopefuls had to
adjust to a new normal
even figuring out how and where to train
became a challenge
my living room doesn't really have the
best my coffee table
can be the beam instead world champions
lifted weights at a local park
or in a garage next to holiday
decorations teams practiced together by
zoom
the kids playroom became the gym with
curious family pets as new training
partners
athletes in some sports fared better
than others requiring more contact
it was probably two and a half months
with very very limited training fencer
darrell homer won a silver medal in rio
in the men's saber match and is trying
to make his third olympic team
fencing is a sport that requires
equipment coaches
a fencing club to train in training
partners training
and you're normally in a club of 30 to
40 people and you have
the more training partners the better in
the pandemics early days
homer honed his skills from his harlem
apartment
you had mentioned doing footwork on your
roof was that
did you ever do that before all of this
no never i would never have dreamed of
doing that before this snow
the added year will also mean less money
for athletes no longer winning prize
money from competitions
or bonuses from sponsors that's been
really tough for a lot of different
people out there just trying to make
ends meet and
i know a lot of their worries were like
okay can i even hang in there for next
year am i going to be able to
financially
hang on until the olympics dr lea lagos
is a clinical and sports psychologist
who treats olympic athletes
can these athletes deal with so much
change
yes she calls burnout in the next year a
major concern
this is a devastating period for many of
them and while they're
resilient by nature and nurture
many of them are going through a
struggle there's a chance
the tokyo olympics won't happen at all
if they aren't held in 2021
organizers say the games will be
canceled which has only happened during
world wars
1 and 2. if the olympics don't happen
how long does it take an athlete to
readjust and figure out their new
purpose in life
in terms of recovery it's very
individual it can take years
sometimes and so in particular instances
to heal and
others it can be a few weeks or not at
all
a lot of these athletes would be gutted
murber has already re-examined his goals
rediscovering his love of the sport in
the meantime
in his running career merber has
competed almost exclusively
in the 1500 meter race but is now using
the extra year to train for longer
distance races
more suited to his age we no longer say
that you are training for the olympics
and yet you are still trying to make the
2021
games what do you mean by that i'm
interested in pursuing
a professional career beyond just
professional running
my latin i'm interested in
you know starting a family with my wife
and you know
just maybe taking some vacations that we
wouldn't have otherwise done
and just maybe not sacrificing
every single day in the way that i have
maybe eating a little bit more ice cream
for homer the pause and olympic training
gave him more time to devote to
increasing diversity in fencing
he also participated in black lives
matter protests this summer
as athletes were flying especially
fencing like it's a global sports we're
flying around
every three weeks you know it's hard to
kind of ground yourself in what
what's happening around people around
communities or in your community
as for hernandez she says the extra year
of training may ultimately help her
the gymnast had taken two years off
after rio
i know that my comeback was really late
i knew that going into it
but this extra year gives me a lot of
time to maybe get some upgrades and get
a little more consistent
and i want to experience the olympics
again but at 20 so i can really
take in everything because at 16
ignorance is bliss the olympic motto
translates to faster higher stronger
and the athletes hoping to be crowned
the best in the world
are now developing a new kind of
resilience and
purpose now at 29 i've kind of redefined
my idea of what it means to be
successful
you know no longer will i let the
olympic
rings determine whether or not i've had
the success that i've hoped
i think it's just the day-to-day of
enjoying what you're doing
and the pursuit of it for cbs this
morning saturday
nancy chen new york
interesting also training now for tokyo
next year
no former athletes i was saying during
the
while the piece was airing that i always
wanted to cover the olympics
i have not done that yet you on the
other hand have done it many times
done four or five games always one of
the most fascinating things the
intersection of
culture economics sports so much to uh
to talk about but it's
i mean imagine working your entire life
at one moment
right and you're weeks away from it and
then
you're either delayed or can't do it
it's tough